d'alsace une chose est sûre haut-rhin et
bas-rhin auront leur propre espace à la
57e édition du salon de l'agriculture à
paris le coup d'envoi sera donné le 22
février deux espaces distincts seront
mis en place pour promouvoir
l'agriculture alsacienne
le projet porté par les conseils
départementaux du bas rhin et du haut
rhin a été présenté ce matin au magasin
du verger expérimental de obernai
reportage de la drire labit et cannes et
roland
tout y est les colombages les pommes
nati les bretzels ou encore les fameuses
cigognes la présence de ces symboles
dans les allées du salon de
l'agriculture marque le retour de
l'alsace porte de versailles depuis
l'arrivée du grand est la bannière de la
marque alsace se faisait plus discrète
chaque année au salon j'étais toujours
obligé comme tout le public est bien de
chercher où se trouvaient les stands de
l'alsace il était très difficile à
trouver parce que très peu visible pas
lisible puisque noyé dans un immense
espace du grand est aujourd'hui avec le
conseil départemental du bas-rhin avec
la chambre d'agriculture d'alsace et l'
agence du tourisme alsace destination
tourisme et bien nous avons à la fois un
stand de l'alsace et puis nous avons
habillé les stands des exposants
alsacien et pour plus de visibilité et
la promotion de l'agriculture alsacienne
se déclinera en deux concepts aux quatre
un espace ter alsace agriculteurs et
plus encore qui se déploiera sur 120
mètres carrés et dans lequel seront
valoriser les filières agricoles et plus
loin dans le hall 3 villages alsace et
ses colombages caractéristiques
accueillera les exposants alsacien en
tout ils seront treize producteurs dont
trois nouveaux à présenter leurs
produits tels que le pain d'épicés la
bière ou encore la traditionnelle
choucroute qui fait l'attractivité de
l'alsace
c'est notamment notre gastronomie et non
une gastronomie c'est de la fourche à la
fourchette c'est d'abord bien sûr
d'excellents produits venus de
l'activité agricole c'est ensuite nos
chefs et nos équipes de l'art de la
table qui font que c'est un bonheur de
partager un repas en alsace donc à deux
stands un stand dans le hall 3 qui
permettra à des agriculteurs d'être
présents et de montrer la qualité de
leurs produits et un autre hall 4 un
rôle plus institutionnel qui là ne
permettra de mettre en avant les
filières autour de l'agriculture les
filières courtes aussi tout le travail
que nous menons pour les collèges les
ehpad pour faire en sorte que les
produits du terroir investissent investi
ces lieux avec ses 630 3000 visiteurs en
2019 dont 32 me professionnels le salon
de l'agriculture est la plus grande
manifestation agricole européenne
vitrine du territoire ces retombées
économiques et sur l'emploi agricole
sont elles pour autant importante pour
les participants
nous remarquons que le citoyen ne
connaissent pas l'agriculture ne
connaissent plus l'agriculture
donc c'est toujours un moment important
de montrer nos animaux comment nous les
soignons de montrer nos produits et de
montrer aussi un petit peu plus comment
nous les produisons qu'on arrive
difficilement à valoriser de suite
cette présence disons rentable à long
terme puisque quelque part en terme de
communication c'est important que nous
soyons présents et aussi par rapport au
retour que nous pouvons avoir sur les
produits alsaciens qu'elles sont
rentables ou non l'opération à un coût
trois cent mille euros pour les deux
départements tout au long de la semaine
et les grandes filières régionales
seront représentés à l'espace ter alsace
vins et crémants fruits et légumes ou
encore houblon et les journées du 23 et
24 février seront consacrés à des
animations alsacienne au village alsace